hello
and welcome to drew crime this is a
crime series dedicated
to people who are victims of crime named
drew in tonight's episode we are
featuring drew barrymore she got herself
in a very sticky situation
it turns out someone put a sweet treat
on her toilet seat
i'm going to sit down with drew very
cautiously of course
and get to the bottom of those honey
buns
drew thank you so much for joining us
walk us through what happened
it started out like any other night i
was with my daughters
and i had to go to the bathroom but when
i sat down on the toilet
i could immediately tell that something
wasn't right
why was that true well my bottom
it was sticky
that must have been awful it was
so viscous
and suddenly i was craving hot tea and
that's how i knew
it was honey
how did that feel to have honey on your
bottom i mean it clearly felt like a
professional
job what did your daughter say
when you asked them about the toilet
honey
you're calling me honey no no the toilet
honey you know either is fine well i
don't know if you know this drew but
putting honey on a toilet is a popular
prank on tick tock
it is
that's interesting
hold on hoda
did you put honey on the toilet seat
oh i wish she would have told me
why would i tell you me and my friend
marlo did it as a prank
oh yeah touche okay
well thanks honey i love you
well drew it looks like another job done
here on drew crime
thank you hoda now i feel so much better
about being stuck to a toilet feet
[Music]
you